[Musique]
comment concilier confinement et
activité physique des cours de sport via
les écrans et ça existait déjà en 1966
et c'est comme toujours par la mise en
traque commence votre séance
d'entraînement dominique à l'émission
tous en forme était diffusée toutes les
semaines juste avant la messe
vous pourrez donc sur la pointe des
pieds pendant quelques secondes et vous
ajoutez à ces fours et de bons mots
voies respiratoires dix minutes
d'enchaînements et de précieux conseils
vous ajoutez un petit mouvements de
flexion extension de job un petit
mouvement de tête aussi toujours pour la
grâce de mouvement comme les coaches sur
youtube
le présentateur s'adressait directement
aux téléspectateurs un exercice très
complet alors j'ai pas besoin de vous
dire qu'au début il vous sera peut-être
difficile si vous arrivez depuis peu à
notre leçon matinale de l'effectuer plus
de quatre ou cinq fois sans éprouver
déjà de la fatigue
mais la vraie révolution du sport à
domicile
c'est en 1982 et ce sont elles bonjour
je suis véronique bonjour je suis davina
pendant quatre ans sur antenne 2 le
collants fluo étaient de mise le
dimanche matin aux halles et kit est ce
que vous êtes en train de faire et venez
vite avec nous l'émission pouvait
attirer jusqu'à 12 millions de
téléspectateurs bon alors maintenant
c'est le moment de folie
c'est le moment où on se défoule on y va
gym tonic s'est arrêté en 1986 quelques
années plus tard internet a pris le
relais aujourd'hui en plus du kimono
il est équipé d'un micro pour dispenser
une leçon de sport mais devant lui
personne à part trois caméraman la leçon
que donne ce sportif est enregistrée et
sera disponible sur un site internet
et avec ce site internet on peut donc
faire du sport chez soi confortablement
installé dans son salon
roxana maracineanu ministre des sports a
recommandé une activité de 30 minutes
par jour pendant la période de
confinement
[Musique]